des meubles de l'électroménager des
vêtements de seconde main un petit prix
depuis le mois de mai la recyclerie
rebond a ouvert à mèche un lieu qui
séduit pour son aspect économique et
écologique bien comme c'est les habits
sont recyclés en l'air mais une deuxième
fois donc ça évite d'acheter trop de
choses nouvelles j'ai une deuxième vie
pour les vêtements et chez son vinaigre
un projet porté par l'association rebond
soutenu par les collectivités et préval
le magasin a également une vocation
sociale
treize employés ils sont en insertion à
presque 48 ans annabella rêve d'un
emploi stable elle est originaire du
portugal on a un arrivage tous les
vendredis donc on enlève les anciens et
puis on met la nouveauté j'avais jamais
fait de vente donc c'était la première
expérience dans la vente donc griffon
play et rémy s'occupe lui de la
réception des objets ils vérifient que
ce combi données réutilisables
il est arrivé à un rebond car son
apprentissage s'est mal passé pour
retrouver du travail après j'ai pas
forcément plus haut que du coup je resté
bloqué chez moi un petit moment il a du
coup la recyclerie rebonds là il me
donne une chance pour me réinsérer dans
le travail donc ça je te remercie
le but pour ces personnes en insertion
acquérir de nouvelles expériences et
résoudre les freins à l'emploi la
structure est juste là de façon
temporaire pour les leur permettre de
rebondir vers justement un emploi
durable dans une entreprise
traditionnelle
depuis son ouverture le magasin tourne à
plein régime
les socios a même surpassé ses objectifs
à l'avenir il espère tirer organisait
plus d'ateliers en lien avec l'économie
circulaire